et alors très rapidement parce que je
sais qu'on n'a pas beaucoup de temps
donc nolwenn leroy sera toujours samedi
20 octobre à 20h30 à la ferme du manet à
montigny vous pouvez réserver avoir les
infos sur le site de la ville
www.montignac.com 18 point fr autres
autres artistes suzanne vega à la
batterie de guyancourt le même soir à
20h30
les infos sont à et les réservations
sont effectuées sur le site de la
batterie de guyancourt point fr et puis
ce soir n'oubliez pas gong si ça vous
intéresse à au scarabée de la verrière
c'est à 20h30
merci jouanin pour ce point complet sur
la culture comme chaque mercredi on va
parler encore culture pendant quelques
instants conclure ce set 8 avec les 10
ans de parcours dans l'art actuel c'est
à versailles pour l'instant vos sorties
ciné vos réactions à la sortie des
premières projections des nouveaux films
à l'affiché en ce 17 octobre
on a vu passer leur retraite moi j'ai
trouvé ça franchement pitoyable comme
les jolies nanas qui sont jaloux de tous
elles sont déjà jolie de quoi ils se
plaignent chez pas enfin bref non jeu
franchement si vous n'avez qu'un film
allez voir c'est pas celui-là sérieux
puis c'est un peu grossier c'est un peu
vulgaire c'est un peu c'est too much
c'est du vu et du revu c'est toujours la
même chose
franchement je me suis vraiment ennuyer
astérix obélix et c'était plutôt sympa
comique il parle beaucoup parlent
beaucoup quand même
voilà je viens juste d'aller voir le
dernier astérix et obélix et maaf on
s'est bien amusés il ya pas mal de
références cinématographiques très drôle
pour les adultes et c'est aussi très
drôle pour les enfants donc on a
vraiment passé un très bon moment quoi
on a été voir donc
astérix et obélix au service de sa
majesté le film pour les 6 ans de mon
fils
machete le film qu'on attendait il a
bien apprécié lui c'est le plus
important et puis nous personnellement
très bien apprécié également et
beaucoup d'humour le film est vraiment
bien les acteurs sont vraiment très bon
et on est vraiment surpris par enfin moi
j'étais surpris par zac efron à un film
un peu long
dans le style un peu la louisiane des
années 60 donc avec le racisme et puis
le ku klux klan il n'y a pas que
l'histoire mais une histoire de racisme
beaucoup et puis mais de vraiment un
très bon acteur